we are two years into this pandemic and
everyone is exhausted people are lonely
people have lost loved ones they've lost
jobs others are overworked the
coronavirus has killed more than 5
million people around the world 5
million it's hard to comprehend and it's
understandable some people are angry and
want someone to blame politicians public
health officers and the media are all
targets but on the streets in canada
over the last 11 days things have been
said that i thought i'd never hear in
this country
a state of emergency in canada's capital
the city center paralyzed by people
demanding freedom
profane insults directed at the prime
minister the organizers calling for
parliament to be dissolved
how did it come to this
there's not a journalist in this world
right now there's not one journalist out
there that can write a [ __ ] story
properly
there is a lot to dissect about this
protest and it's important to point out
not everyone is this angry but one
thing's clear we no longer have an
agreed set of facts and journalists
trying to listen to protesters concerns
have become targets
how can you sleep at night with all the
lies
the propagandas themselves it's as if
they've forgotten canada is free you
refuse to tell the truth they can walk
down the street hurling insults
canadians have political rights and
civil liberties we have democratically
elected governments free and fair
elections and a free press
freedom of thought belief opinion and
expression including freedom of the
press is protected by the charter of
rights and freedoms
yet in toronto this happened to a global
news reporter after your convictions
your executions cannot come soon enough
you are the enemy of the people you're
the vile liars
where have we heard that before
a few days ago i called the fake news
the enemy of the people and they are
they are the enemy of the people
when the former u.s president first said
that it sounded shocking
now we hear it on canadian streets
maria ressa an investigative journalist
and co-winner of the 2021 nobel peace
prize
warns of a slide into fascism enabled by
technology
our greatest need today
is to transform that hate and violence
the toxic sludge that's coursing through
our information ecosystem prioritized
by american internet companies that make
more money by spreading that hate
and triggering the worst in us
triggering the worst in us
we are all tired of public health
restrictions when and how to loosen them
is worth civil debate
this
is not that
ressa and others believe there is an
insidious manipulation happening at
scale and we're only beginning to wrap
our heads around it
as she says without facts you can't have
truth without truth you can't have trust
without trust we have no shared reality
no democracy